[Musique]
monsieur le ministre vous venez
d'effectuer un parcours à bord du tgv du
turbo train en compagnie d'ailleurs du
secrétaire américain aux transports
quelles sont vos premières impressions
de passagers ses premières impressions
sont évidemment excellente parce que
c'est assez impressionnant d'aller à 300
à l'heure et de ne pas s'en apercevoir
mais la rapidité la souplesse le confort
sont les caractéristiques du turbo train
et je pense que ce sont les réactions
également de mon collègue le ministre
des transports américain nouveau
ministre des transports français le
turbo tra est une arme d'avenir dans
quelle mesure va-t-il entrer rapidement
un service aux particuliers pour
décongestionner bordeaux vous savez j'ai
annoncé l'autre jour à la foire de fées
rigueur que le tueur votera seraient en
service l'été prochain entre bordeaux et
lyon je crois que c'est une grande
nouvelle pour perry que pour bordeaux et
pour lyon monsieur le ministre
quelles ont été vos premières
constatations dans ce nouveau prototype
français de très très très impressionné
il n'y a pas d'équivalent en amérique
tu sais très bien ce que j'espère voir
des trains de souge en service dans les
régions trafic américaine
est ce que les états unis seraient
intéressés éventuellement par le turbo
sera français by the french touch ring
et as we would be oui serait douteuse à
bien
[Musique]